arresting a pastor for holding a church
service it's not like that's
some video out of you know 1930s europe
or russia
this is canada it's not the united
states yet but could it come down to
that
just up in our neighbor to the north
america's hat over
the past week a that pastor that polish
pastor up there
whose name is arthur pavlovsky leave it
to the polls to always be defending
freedom
and western christendom
pavlovsky was arrested in the middle of
a street
by a swat team in canada for inciting
people
to go to church seeing that look
looks like a fairly busy road
there are the cops hands behind his head
he's on his knees
he's wearing a suit to go preach to his
congregation
hello friends this is pastor art
polowski if you're watching this video
that means they have successfully
arrested me
and i am in jail if you would like to
support me
if you like to support rebel news and
the legal team that is trying their best
to get me out of this trouble
please go to safearthur.com
please donate please help help me help
my family help my
wife and my children to get me out of
this
horrible illegal situation
please go to safearthur.com and get me
out of this
so this is the pastor we played him on
the show month or so ago whenever
whenever he had his first stand against
these people
and he wouldn't let the the public
health police come into his
congregation and he called them gestapo
and he called them
nazis and communists and you know the
polls know a thing or two about what
about this topic
this is canada it's not the united
states yet
but it's going to create a very strange
situation here because if the cops ever
start doing that in america god forbid
is the right gonna back the blue i'm not
gonna back the blue if the blue
is is arresting pastors i don't think
they would do that in america
or i don't think they would want to do
that in america but could it come down
to that
what those cops are they are behaving
like gestapo that's how else do you
describe it
to arrest someone for for holding a
church service
they don't arrest other people for
holding other gatherings
this is specific the churches close and
the marijuana dispensaries remain open
in california during the lockdown
this is not about a uniform standard
it's about creating a new
ranking of priorities and an upending
of the culture and if we don't stand up
against it now
it's it's not like that's some video out
of you know 19
1930 europe or russia
that's happening right now right up to
the north just last week
so you've got the police force in canada
arresting a pastor for holding a church
service because he is
violating the state established church
of
secular progressivism he's violating the
true priests of canada
who are the public health experts and
we've got the same thing here folks it's
not quite as far down the line as it is
in canada
but we've got the same sort of thing
here the same kind of rules on the books
the same kind of punishments albeit to a
lesser degree
hey there stop i'll make this quick ring
the bell just ring the bell
it's not hard it's not complicated
there's not a huge explanation here
ring the bell like subscribe and then
you will not miss a notification and you
will get to see more of these videos
thank you very much see you next time
[Music]
you